because they want to be in our shoes Oh
certainly certainly it's exciting to
watch the development of these young
prodigies and how far they're going to
go they're always it's always guesswork
to see how far they go into chess and
what life will bring them
I had brought that the game between s
Warren and Anna's at an ski up on my
screen because I was very curious to see
how they got into this particular
position
Maurice pegged it accurately this was a
tepid play by white trading all of the
pieces I'm guessing that ass Warren
wasn't familiar with the subtleties of
this particular line of the French black
equalised comfortably after 96 and now
whites move Bishop a six this was a nice
move a very important tactic because
first of all if we go back a second I
mean White's not developed and if you're
allowed Black Knight takes e5 and say
after move like F takes e5 this Bishop
on b7 raining down against the g2 pawn
is is going to tie White's pieces up to
its defense so this move Bishop a six
developing with a gain of tempo was a
very clever before could be a little bit
also you don't really want to leave the
knight on e5 either do you what you're
trying to say is that now forcing me to
basics on Knight takes c6 and Anna
didn't like this position because her
rook actually has an awkward position
decision to make one of the things is
that if you play a move I just put it
down because I always loved these Knight
forks rook d7 oops
the knight attacks from behind forking
rook and Bishop so anna had to decide it
I should say
decided to play the move Bishop
eight and then that meant that white was
able to develop with the gain of tempo
and then rook g1 Knight takes e5 Queen
takes e5 I believe was played and now
Anna as Maurice was pointing out Queen
takes e5 f takes he you would normally
want to capture that
but then rook d5 could get you into
trouble after the c2 c4 so move like
King f8 preparing keen e7 and we're
going to what we are in an ending and
we're going to see if black can use her
King sight majority where as whites
Queen side majority for the moment as
dormant so still I would say on a slight
slight advantage so probably as well and
we'll want to advance that pawn on g2
yeah it's not so simple though because
after the move g2 g3 the rook d5 comes
with a double attack first obviously we
want to pick up this key central unit
but also rook a5 I could force your
Bishop rook David one haha well that
makes it that makes so much sense
doesn't it I apologize not so
comfortable the end game you could point
out from yesterday so if she can find a
position where she has a small edge I
think the practical edge will be great
by can trade rook so right well B if she
can't find a line where she can maintain
some activity with rooks on the board I
think it's gonna be harder for her to
squeeze something out of this don't you
think
especially if white is able to play rook
d1 and you can't meet this move with
rook c8 you know like you're prepared to
give up the D file so you can get play
on the C file that of course c8 is
covered by the bishop so and a rook
trade going into a straight heads-up
Bishop ending that looks really drawn
I've got plenty
- stop that - exactly yeah this will be
a challenge for the four-time champion
to try to squeeze some juice out of this
mm-hmm and we've got a Maurice with us
in another game over in the championship
indeed we saw a Cobian really show his
stuff yesterday against garea winning a
game that a lot of us thought he was
going to lose after drawing four games
in a row he won this game against garea
to bring himself back into contention in
the championship and it looks like he is
well on his way to potentially winning
yet another game against Ramirez if you
look at this opening with a white it
looked like he might have been in some
danger have a giving up a pawn he was
willing to play a little bit loose in
this position giving up this pawn and
maybe at some point being able to play
the move b5 yes I know you like that
idea but Ramirez didn't go for it at all
he played 96 attacking this pawn and
after Queen c2 defended it he played
them on c5 which is a completely
different approach and after D takes e5
Queen to a5 Akopian said okay now I'm
back I haven't lost anything at all
you're the one who has to get material
back Queen takes e5 Bishop to d3 and now
this move Knight B to d7 bringing the
knight out maybe potentially going to e5
I'm not sure about this move and this
one is going to cost him because after
castles a six look at this Queen to e2
sacrificing a pawn again saying if you
want it take it
I dare you in this situation Bishop
takes on c3 B takes on c3 Queen takes on
c3 was definitely playable but highly
dangerous a couple of moves here
Bishop to a3 is possible even Bishop to
d2 starting to take potshots at that
Queen the Queen has to go back on the C
file another rook will show up and this
dark square Bishop is turning into a
monster could end up on b4 preventing
the King from castling that would have
been a problem so instead of doing that
Ramirez decided to play the move e5 he
didn't want to see this point advanced
either but guess what a Cobian pounced
he played the move Knight a2 wanting
that bishop he understands the dark
square weakness in the position for
example the move Bishop back to a
five could have been played but he would
have insisted with the move be four come
on give me that Bishop it's all I want
so that I can keep your queen first of
all attack your queen and keep your King
locked in the center of the board here
believe it or not even though he's not
winning a piece any time soon Houdini is
giving this position a full three-point
advantage that's like being up a whole
piece he's saying the King can castle
how would these pieces gonna untangle
themselves White has full development I
give the odds of Kobe and winning this
game at at least 90% huge edge for him
in this position so here 982 ramirez
decided to castle and give up his dark
square bishop a little surprising
he took it first instead of developing
his bishop on this square and then
taking it Queen takes before let's see
if we can get the current position in
the game yeah this is the current
position in the game and Houdini loves
black loves white here giving him a
one-point advantage which is about a
pawn edge basically saying that a lot of
space the great bishop and blacks pieces
the dark squares will be a challenge in
this position the move b3 is what it's
suggesting threatening Bishop to a3 even
though he's sacrificing this pawn we saw
the line where the bishop this bishop
becomes a dominant piece so a Cobian in
the driver's seat here I think he
shouldn't have traded right away but
still he's got to be happy with his game
and I'm not sure it looks like he did
find the move b3 I believe that is what
he played showing his stuff as number
four player in the tournament looking to
try to make an even greater move
especially with Lindemann in trouble if
Cobian wins and Lenderman loses he's
tied for first in the championship back
to you guys how quickly things turned
out for those of you stuck with us today
we've got a special treat for you
oh yeah sir results what I've never
heard great photos I love that hairstyle
in the lab oh my god you're not to be
but the question is when in doubt take
them on and
you read the rest of them her position
is not bad it's really really really bad
cover your eyes kids this is going to
get ugly
okay she doesn't have her I'm going to
win face on in a dream world let me show
you what the dream is my surfer
no that was my fro and my surfer look oh
boy oh boy okay let's let's move let's
move quickly away from that discussion
let's take a look at Mac versus Ray
Robson and they do have a very combative
position when Maurice had looked at it
he had looked at it pretty early
this advanced e4 e5 since black was not
playing d7 d6 Mac decided hey let me
give you night the boot with a with a
gain of a tempo 'if I've Knight attack
bishop on e3 the bishop dropped back and
since Ray was worried that this Knight
over here on g4 might get stranded
he played f7 f6 breaking up White's
center team he 5f4 there was a trade
Knight takes g2 g3 is a possibility that
this pawn on f4 could be a target for
blacks pieces and white is setting up
for playing Bishop g2 Knight a5 castles
b5 Bishop g2 it should be 7 a trade
bishop f2 protecting the h1 rook of
course rook c8 queen d3 castles
Knight f3 so what Mac wants to do he
wants to establish his knight in the
center of the board and by the way also
the idea of Knight g5 with Queen h7
ideas Kentico black b v b4 of
epical idea in the night or kick this
knight on c3 backwards or wherever and
Knight a 4 was played Knight B 5 okay
because the night went to the a for
square black doesn't want to see the
knight rerouting itself to be six so
this move by rain 95 it makes perfect
sense your black protects the B Square B
six square and the knight on d5 in the
middle of the board is a beast now on
the other hand pawn structure favors
white the good play for black I like
what Ray has done in this game
how about yourself Jen do you would I
know you like to play the Sicilian from
both sides but maybe you would like
White's position storming down the board
like you normally would so not as
excited about it as I am about most
Sicilian positions for white that being
said I think that neither left three of
the bishop on earth - if improved to
create a little bit of unpleasantness to
wait for black so I mean I move like
Bishop d4 I could say improving if
improvement is what you want you can get
that right away with a move like Bishop
d4 or for that matter ninety five as
well yeah you want to do both which is
understandable well just improving your
position is a good idea as well I mean
eight four eight five eight six is in
the cards but it's a bit slow well I can
understand why you would be attracted to
the move Age 4 because okay let's just
put it on the board because let's say
black plays a move like rook c7 makes
perfect sense doubling rooks down the C
file right this it was this tickle and
you did by eliminating the night you
don't eliminate the threat because the
rook on h1 is suddenly brought into the
game after H takes you
and now g6 really weakens the dark
squares we saw that that wasn't so
pleasant actually we saw Lenderman get a
drug in siren burger but Ehrenburg was
on the positive side of that drive oh
definitely and Sergei really actually
was kicking himself during the postgame
interview that he gave here where Heath
he felt that he really messed up and
that he let Lenderman escape what Sergei
felt was a loss position for his
opponent might even be some immediate
threats in this position like I'm not
sure about rook takes h7 but I would
like to put the position on the board
after workout 700 I apologize I
apologize
so h4 I just bought Lucy's have you're
sure about dreams that okay absolutely
let's do it made on one on the board
right Bishop d4 molnár versus Ramirez
Bishop d4 you wanted to say rook f7 and
you wanted to show how girls played some
poor guy
purple gar yeah it's following her
checkmate like this right I was thinking
maybe somebody would play rock a 7
because rook takes 87 might be in the
air because of her cage 1 check in GA in
Queen takes g6 yeah so kind of
interesting but of course this is not
force dr. Knight g5 instead of playing
g5 or in this position you can play
something different than what c7 right I
I'm thinking that I may want to stop the
threat altogether of 95 with the move
h7h sex but in that case the inclusion
of h4 and h6 is a nice idea for white I
mean you still could consider a piece
Accra Feist like Knight g5 but I'm
thinking that overall Rey should be
pleased because he still he's he's the
proud possessor of the open C file so
doesn't want to let's say after age six
let's just play a few more moves after
say Bishop d4 rook c7 what ray wants to
do is swing his rook to c8 doubling his
rooks down the C file and then this
knight on a five it can come into the
game nicely with Knight c4 and don't
forget this night on the eighth floor
makes a strange impression if you don't
if you don't deal well after moves like
Knight c4 there is a squeen b5 and this
night on a four could end it up can end
up costing you the game to a threat of
Queen b5 and that's exactly why you kind
of like black even the white still has
some traditional Sicilian play um you're
not feeling that night on a four I don't
blame you mm-hm I would like to remind
everybody that if you're already
starting to miss house we've got half a
tournament left but we're also gonna be
back sync up right coming up in late
August
featuring some of the world's top chess
players it starts Wednesday August 27th
we don't have a player list for you yet
but keep a close eye on the seanwes
chess club Facebook Twitter and website
and those names should be confirmed in
the next month or so right right well
contracts are being have been sent out
and we're getting some very positive
feedback as you well know and we're just
hopeful that the elite event of the year
will be held in st. Louis yeah let's put
it like that yesterday a big missed
opportunity by the player with the black
pieces here Katarina Nemcova Victorian
II played a while to move she had
already sacrificed a pawn in the opening
in order to get some play to entrench
her night on the f5 square to have a
strong Queen on this side no mating
threats as yet but then she played a
seriously wild move the move before
attacking the knight simply inviting the
move Knight to d3 now
that's a truly powerful looking move the
knight hitting the rook of a bishop and
the pawn on e5 how do you defend it all
there are no tricks there's no funny
business here the only move to actually
stay in the game is the wild rook to e3
if she instead had tried to defend this
Bishop then she would have had to answer
the question what's wrong with me just
snapping a pawn off and being up to
pawns now instead of doing that rook to
e3 is playable
because after Knight takes on c1 now
this Knight is trapped so the move
Knight to c3 or even Knight to d2 is
playable this Knight of course potential
force but it looks like White has
everything covered
but now the move Bishop to g5 hitting
the rook through to the knight and if
you play f4 to stop that now the bishop
drops back sneaky move because now the
Queen no longer defends the b-pawn and
black can just grab this pawn and
Houdini saying what's the deal it's a
free pawn
there's no mate why not instead of doing
that black in this position believes her
opponent after b4 and played the simple
Knight to e6 and now Houdini saying
white is just fine
whoo gotta be feeling good right now of
real missed opportunity by name Cova
playing to passively instead of going
for it she didn't want to risk it but it
might come back to haunt her back to you
guys and we've got some really exciting
news in another women's championship
game in a swore ons game against adoptee
they're viv some exciting developments
we were looking at some positions with a
queen trader we were saying is that how
can he gonna be able to squeeze anything
out of this and instead of going for the
Queen trade she played Queen to h4 and I
had a crucial moment right we were just
back a moment ago the Queen was on e5 we
were looking at these end games and
deciding they really didn't offer her
much in the way of winning chances he
won timely ideas thereby as far on so
after Queen h4 ideas of Queen takes h2
and Queen f2 on the agenda
I swore and jumped in the the position
so I hold back that Queen on h4 so on a
year played the distracting
the Commission takes G - Wow we can't
take on G - because one Queen bet you
won me now would you describe this as a
back rank mate yes me too
okay but it's kinda like a diagonal
slash right that's why you have to do 20
push-ups and 20 of those obliques legs
because of the slash penalty for that
one - okay so now the question is what
about Queenie five again we're not going
back that you five what happens then is
now that Bishop on g2 isn't Kate because
regarding the e1 Square right but now
Queen age two comes back into the
position Queen takes H - Queen F - and
no longer do we have any pressure on the
rependa game right so we don't like this
that's not gonna work so let's make a
lift
perhaps so Mickey left and now we
actually are 31 kg Cara
so the bishop would presumably just drop
back to e4 and I don't know I was
looking very good if she gets her Bishop
to g6 would lift her so her Kings gonna
be super safe super solid we have our
snatch on 87 and b6 the problem is a
force on you attack exactly f4 would be
hanging with check to Black's Queen so
it looks like just going back here to
Queen h4 for a moment a calculating a
calculation error perhaps on behalf of
Aswan maybe she didn't know didn't find
a better way of dealing with blacks
various threats of Queen f2 so in any
case Queen c7 I like this
when in doubt grabbed the pawn bishop
takes g2 and his war on having to figure
out what do I do now she just did a pawn
her King looks to be the problem here
doesn't exactly the king is not secure
and it's not easy for white here to
really develop a threat because this
Queen h4 h Wan checkmate is so annoying
I guess we're going to have to play
Bishop d3 no real threat and
position that I'm just redirecting my
Bishop to the King site and trying to
prevent black from playing Bishop efore
herself so that was why I played the
move Bishop d3 but lots of choices here
by for Anna including just I don't know
making lifts and then the G file is not
going to bring anything special to white
Maurice if you could share your thoughts
in this position because it is a big big
moment for the young lady shritha and
it's a big moment for the tornament
because if the Tatsuki wins this games
and she's right back in there looking at
it with Irina crash arena doesn't pull
it out that's right well I read a crush
this game today is just getting started
I don't
with all the sites of games we can't bet
on a draw but it doesn't look like she
has a big advantage or anything like
that
exactly so Anna taught to play as well
so any result as possible in that game
right whereas the Tomsky looks to be in
control in her game and actually I think
Maurice has something for us in a
different game in Mona Robson in DJ let
me pull that game up and go back a few
moves I was analyzing this position and
it looks as though Robson has a cold-cut
win after this move Queen to e4 by white
Robson can just continue on the attack
with the move rook to c4 and blacks
pieces are just swarming around White's
King Plus this knight looks awful on the
a Foursquare what to do about this move
if you were to drop your Queen back for
example you run into this nasty shot b3
and now the threat is here on the c2
pawn with the rook the threat is on the
a to pawn looking to Queen a capture
here can be met by Knight takes with
check of course you can't play Queen
takes Knight because of Queen takes
Queen and you cannot capture back due to
the pin on the file so in this position
here I have to check you have to go in
the corner and now white could simply
black could simply take on a four or
even drop the knight back because this
Knight has no home where's it supposed
to go it's just under heavy fire he
can't go into b6
if it drops back to c3 it's just gonna
get snapped off again the pin on the
line so here white is in huge trouble
after this move rook to c4 if Ray finds
it it's almost all she wrote in this
position the other rook is coming to the
file the b3 move is almost here black is
totally dominant and Ray Robinson simply
has to find the move let's see whether
or not he did and he still has not yet
moved in the game but rook to c4 is
simply crushing if he finds that move
young ray Robson will be back in the
winner's circle and he's hovering over
the board now I doubt he's gonna miss
this Ray's just too good
we'll see and keep an eye on this next
very critical moment in this game here
are the championships back to you guys
poor McKenzie baller I mean he's a great
player but having a tough time in the
championship and I think maybe his
confidence has been affected because you
know he made that blunder against grey
head right yesterday he was losing but
still can't feel good to miss Matawan
psychologically right you know
Ramirez gave a very gentlemanly kind of
explanation that when you're losing it
doesn't really matter just play the
brain apartment still can't feel good
and then missing work c4 we have a
youngster
Oxshott Chandra of cuesta GM he made his
first GM norm quite recently at the
Marshall chess club you have mentioned
the end he says Mulder seems to have
blundered against Robson DeWitt 20
community for his receipt for it looks
absolutely crushing indeed that's no
information yeah exactly
well one of the questions I'm often
asked by knowledgeable club players is
what's it what are the differences
between grandmasters yeah like and
here's a prime example really Mac
started very well he drew his first
three games I believe and they're good
good heart fights but he lost a game got
rattled lost again and it appears after
this move rook c4 that I'm sure raised
about to pounce on he may lose again
and that's the difference between really
really elite grandmasters is that they
stop the bleeding if you lose one game
they recover and sometimes it's
incredibly hard to recover when you get
into the cycle where you know nothing's
going wrong nothing's going right pardon
me and that's that that's a big
difference between grandmasters and
elite Grandmaster mental toughness I
want to just say too like sometimes you
just have to will yourself not to lose
or just you know you know it's like the
force of nature you just take it on
yourself I'm gonna win today I'm gonna
win today I mean I played in so many
tournaments with Gary Kasparov
where his at the board presence his
desire his willpower was overwhelming
just overwhelmed his opponents of time
sometimes even Michael tal for example
was accused of hit hypnotizing his
opponents because of the way he won so
many games in a combinative sacrificial
way the force of will sometimes it comes
down to tell we use this word a lot in
poker
mm-hm but I think chess players
experience it as well that right it's a
it's not a character flaw just something
they have to really work on realizing
that if they lose a lot of games in a
row it doesn't mean that they're weaker
player right that they just can start
from zero at any nine and you know
remember at the sink we were just
talking about coming back up in August
yeah nothing more it dealt with his
worst foe he swore on and got he got two
solid rolls and he was actually on the
positive side I believe in both of them
but definitely the black side lon
and in the white side he was doing well
- he was yeah
this and that we will take a little
commercial break and feel free to submit
your questions and comments to our
hashtag us chess chumps and comments at
st. Louis chess club org and we're gonna
leave you with a little Bobby Fischer
puzzle try to solve it already and we'll
be back with more for the championship
most of my students you gotta look at
all the captures you gotta look at all
the checks but what else you got to look
at all the checkmate threads right
mm-hmm
the checkmating thread so here the
correct answer is just queen a5 putting
extra pressure on a3 and maureesa will
tell us why thanks Jen
well here's my four fold threat matrix
that I always tell my students about
first of all the most forcing move in
chess is a check you have to do
something about it that's big-time and
somebody says check you've got to make a
move so you've got to check when you're
in a position you got to study all the
possible checks because it may lead to
something of course it doesn't always
lead to something the second most
forcing move is a threat to checkmate
you can't ignore those those are just
too powerful the third most force most
forcing move is a capture if I take
something you will likely have to take
something back because if you don't
you're going to be down material and
then the fourth the most forcing is the
threat to capture something I'm going to
take something obviously it'll end up in
category three
so those four forcing moves must always
be studied in every position to see
whether or not one of those will lead to
something decisive well in this position
Fischer has different ideas but he
doesn't have a check that leads anywhere
the Queen check gets kicked out that's
the first in our order of the threat
matrix Queen check does nothing after
Queen takes Queen just leads to a normal
position but the threat to checkmate
hello
the movie played now that serious
because Hui takes pawn King back in
Queen takes a one mate
is on tap White has to stop everything
and pay attention to that move now white
could play the move a four to stop the
mate but unfortunately here comes
another threat to checkmate
rook to b3 and you're in a world of hurt
having split the attackers here Queen
takes a four that is the defender Queen
takes a four is coming and white is
absolutely toast in the game after Queen
a5 madness just gave up his queen for
the rook and Bishop but that did not
help because
Black's Queen became a monster Queen
takes on d5 ripping off the pawn not
giving away at any time to play 97 and
some rogue g8 funny business mate after
rook to g7 Fischer said no problem let
me give it a little check and he gained
time maybe he was a little bit of time
pressure getting to move 40 played these
checks and then after king c1 ripped off
this pawn actually there was no time
pressure he played that maneuver just to
win the pawn and he's gonna win yet
another one and then it's gonna be four
connected passed pawns this
demonstration means nothing at all
madness and look in the position decided
to resign again the typical power
showing by the amazing Bobby Fischer
back to you guys nice finish nice finish
Queen a5 better than Queen c5 because of
Queen a for Maryse earlier head brought
a game to your attention between
Victoria knee and Katja Nemcova and I I
want to take a stab at what the players
were thinking when Victoria went for
that move b4 and I appreciate the
computer says Knight d3 big advantage to
black but when you're sitting at the
board yourself and you're studying the
position and you say oh my god what am I
gonna do about Bishop h6 going after my
pawn on g7 if I grab the rook which was
the idea of the move Knight d3 then
after Bishop takes g7 my goodness I'm
facing threats like Knight h6
checkmate Bishop f6 discovered checkmate
probably both players had missed the
move h7 h5 as a good defense but I mean
at least I can understand why both
players had this blind spot and said oh
my goodness you know Bishop h6 I'm
scared to death of Bishop h6 if I play
g6 well now the rook just moves and
gains a tempo and black is unhappy that
this Bishop is sitting over here on h6
I'm just taking a guess that
that was the variation that both players
were fearful were fearful were fearful
about in terms of tactics the stronger
you get the more you add things to that
you know list of candidate moves that
you must look at every move right right
when you're just starting out it's tough
enough to get them to look at all the
checks and checkmate the rest right you
tell them to look at every all the
captures as well but you know it becomes
harder but then it's also what about
moves that attack the Queen all right
was it attack the rock right there q
it's like a cascading yeah exactly
yes okay so that I did want to take a
stab at you know of course we've got the
computers and they're telling us you
know like the players have missed this
that and the other thing but it's a
different when you're under the pressure
and you don't see that defensive shot
that's right mate right and we've got
developments going on in the leaderboard
Alec Slenderman tactics wow I've got to
have to see what happened here because
there's some strange things going on
let's go back to when we left it I had
been saying for quite some time that I
liked
Sam's position Maurice left it about
here rook c7 Lenderman did jettison a
pawn for a hope for good play for his
two bishops with this knight on d4
however there's still issues there's
another pawn weakness in the position
for white the a3 pawn is weak and black
is still menacing a7 a5 the game
continued rooks e1 putting black and a
pin so that the knight is not going to
grab this pawn on a3 anytime soon the
game continued rook c8 simply defending
Knight f5 hello there's a check in the
position for King King and Queen can for
King king and rook
Knight b6 Wow 96 Wow okay a discovered
attack against the rook there was a
trade Black has two threats he has a
threat to check on the first rank trying
to skewer a rook the second threat is to
capture this night on f5 Lenderman x'
only move in the position was nighty 7
check and now Sam Shanklin to play play
King f8 attacking the knight because
otherwise Bishop do you wanted all those
variations yeah rook the rook c1 check
could the bishop could block but guess
what that bishop
as you just said covering the d1 square
so check - Sam's King King f8 night
night g6 check because takes these sakes
just work c1 King D to work takes h1 and
I suppose there's no good discoveries
there exactly so that's kind of
interesting that we've seen this a
couple of games you're in the
championship side you have this
opportunity to make a double check and
discover check but they don't really do
any great benefit and this pass you on
but that's it and this would be a
winning ending for Sam how easy though
let's say it's five-o because we picked
up upon along the way as well
should be good full exchange upon yeah
full exchange ahead so we got this
position King OOP I beg your pardon we
don't have this position Knight to g6
check and now we're expecting King e8
he's obviously taking on g6 allows
Bishop 86 snagging the rook which we've
been doing all that carnage with
so instead in a g6 check you're
expecting can be eaten
yes so now again white is facing a task
of he's got a deal with this rook c1
check in the position he's got to deal
with the fact that his knight is hanging
I'm supposing he's going to Castle and
he's hoping that black will just be kind
enough just simply to take the knight
and allow a swap
I don't think that Sam's going to allow
that by the way I think that Sam's got
other other and that would just be a
pawn up and game but which is nice
enough perhaps as more as your plan yes
precisely I think that Sam would have
more do you want
precisely so yeah that's not my favorite
but maybe moving that I don't d6 right
moving the knight on d6 is one like nice
little centralizing move like 94 keep in
mind that this Bishop on a b4 is not on
a permanent home and for example let me
just play a move I don't know Knight of
4 or should I play 95 what would you
prefer play 95 ok let's go back a move
so 95 and again blacks are safe solid
pawn to the good and after it moved like
b7 b6 wanting to harass this Bishop I
think he's got the initiative as well it
seems that way release what do you think
I definitely like black in that position
it seems as though white is fighting for
his life but Lenderman fighting back
tenaciously on this board however
there's gonna be no such thing for white
why it is about to get creamed in the
game between molnár and Robson Robson
did play the move rook to c4 a monster
move attacking the Queen preparing the
move b3 and the move rook F c8 and in
this position molar tried rook d4 that
looks like a pretty solid move the rook
has defended a lot by this Knight this
Bishop this Queen everything looks good
the problem is that he's losing cold now
the most natural move to my eyes the
move I play in blitz rook F c8 that wins
in fact Houdini says yeah that's winning
no doubt about it but here's something
sweeter even more funky double of b3
check that out your rooks hanging but
this pawn is going to become a girl
check how I was gonna take on a2 and if
you play rook takes rook
obviously you can't let's just back up
one second mmm here if you play if you
play
pawn takes pawn then after
Knight takes with check your being
forked on the d4 square at the minimum
you're also losing the knight on a five
and a four so that's not a move but
after b3 rook takes on c4 pawn takes
threatening to become a queen king d2
give me that this is just a Houdini
variation that I wanted to show that's
quite spicy the move Knight takes f4 out
of nowhere a shot along this entire
diagonal looking to collect everybody on
this square if you take here Queen takes
this whole sector is under attack blacks
position is just exploded and of course
there's a rook hang what could you do
this check is coming that point is
hanging everything is hanging so after
the move rook to d4 if Rey plays b3
it'll just be a scintillating game again
like I said he could play the solid rook
over the c8 but this would be a nice
piece sacrifice double piece sacrifice
would be really interesting of course
you could also play king b1 but who
wants to look at this position I mean
the King is totally exposed anything
looks ever anything and everything looks
bad as the black pieces would be
swarming all around his King
so Rey Robson will see if he finds the
move b3 but the fact is he doesn't have
to in fact he looked like he didn't
bother with it he did double rooks the
most natural human move in the position
but it's still black for choice so it
looks as though blacks gonna win this
game and come start to come back and
there we see Rey kind of maxing and
relaxing he's like I got this one I know
how to do back to you guys actually that
is very telling that Rey is up from the
board looking at the games from afar
because he's such he's so often in time
trouble he doesn't really have that
luxury often of walking away from the
table but a debt does go to show that
he's very confident in his position well
let's take a look at our hobby and crash
over in the Women's Championship that
Titanic battle I believe that it's going
to be a really intense one because both
of these players are using up a lot of
time you know only 20 considering that
many the opening moves were theory
that's a lot of time so about 20 minutes
showing about 18 minutes for Tata then
22 for Irina quite interesting and we've
got some 26 1826 okay so pretty good
edge and the clock for arena
let's move Knight to c6 what's going on
with it right let's just see how we got
to this because the ladies had a
position like this and I was a little
bit afraid that this move kingi want to
h1 Tatia was preparing to move F to F
for I didn't like that approach that she
took I thought that she should be
trading all four knights f4 was played
takes on d5 and what's left is a pretty
wet nice centralized night in the middle
of the board surely the best piece so
father
exactly f7 f6 just covering the pawn on
e5 before with a very straightforward
idea of getting a passed pawn in the
center either the C pawn at the D pawn
arena captured Knight takes Bishop b5
this is looking good for black I still
like blacks position a day five I am a
c6 square exactly I really like Queen to
b6 okay and I see okay so the fact that
it looked like I read his last move
would prevent to that
well arenas move Queen b6 was designed
to try to dissuade white from jumping in
the center but we have this little
Bishop c4 jack knight c6 d c6 Bishop c4
Chad Bishop c4 check it the idea that if
arena moves her King you want to catch
out okay put me but that doesn't quite
work because King h8 after Queen takes
d6 we fall into another tactic so that
you're right that move came to 8 1
earlier yeah yeah so now there's a
bishop takes g2 in the position that's a
clear and that's a discovered check and
white ends up losing her Queen
after Bishop takes sheet you but instead
can't wait why not this pawn anyway I
don't know like arenas position go back
a second after 96 does taught EF have a
different idea in mind we're looking at
Knight takes c6
so maybe just Bishop takes d5 I don't
like that that much because again we've
got this great night in the center
maybe taught EF is thinking that if she
can get her Bishop to e6 that would be
kind of an equaliser so to speak the
bishop on e6 will be well placed that's
I mean it's better than losing upon
right but you're right that that minor
piece on d4 leaves a great impression
mm-hmm so Battle of the ideas going on
again in this key matchup between a real
fight time champion defending champion
arena crush versus isn't a brie ha myung
try to play the other way and take on c6
and then play some new perhaps some
quiet move to try to round up the part
is it possible I can to keep that Bishop
check and reserve or to play the bishop
check and then to play quite right here
here and perhaps something like this one
and if I have if I try to play Bishop d5
then the problem is at the end of the
variation might be for upon hangs so
right you mean trade trade I was coming
in to c6 but okay we have two bonds yeah
precisely
so again seems like she'd have to go for
the threw out you were right what a very
good knight on d4 and a good bishop on
e6 times I mean looks attractive for
black but at the same time not really a
lot of weaknesses and a lot of trades
going on so perhaps that's that gives
the best chance here to try to minimize
the damage of the night before right so
Rena looking very good
in this position I do I do favor her
game we haven't seen it in a while it's
a heavyweight matchup and it's like the
players have been throwing pillows at
each other rather than haymakers oh I
got the wrong board I'm sorry I wanted
to bring up the game between gada Kamsky
and Alexander oh the way that we
predicted with maybe five and you roofy
six harassing that [ __ ] horn before oh
yes I'm sorry and I pulled up game 1
so in our heavyweight matchup just a lot
of still if just appears a lot a lot of
maneuvering has taken place it's not the
world's most exciting game I'm sorry to
say folks the C file opened up both
players doubled on the C file and the
manoeuvring kept going on and on and on
and white again he's got a nice edge in
space but whether that can be converted
into anything tangible like an extra
pawn or something I'm just saying I'm
gonna just suggest that there's going to
be a lot of hacking down the C file and
then White's position White's pieces are
a little bit better a little bit better
but boy I I mean this is going to be
like squeezing blood out of stone this
is not what I think is going to be
sufficient to give either player any
chances here just that the position is
too static let's go back to our leader
Alex Linderman in trouble against Sam
Shanklin and anyone right because I was
mentioning that this pawn on a3 was a
potential target
also because a7 a5 is in the position
Lenderman is is thinking that he's going
to be forced to drop his bishop back he
didn't want his rook trapped on the f1
square so he played rook a 1 he's a pawn
down trying to put up his best defense
but I see that this is just
I mean if if Sam's technique doesn't
desert her to him Sam Shanklin could be
upsetting our tournament leader who's
had such a phenomenal run so far yeah
Linderman's performing so well that it
feels like an upset but it's not really
an outside of it right it's just that
you know you're playing an opponent
who's having a 2850 TPR tournament
performance rating and your opponent has
white as well so you know that's that
that's a big big result right there
upsetting the literal sense of the word
for sure that would be nice again if
black could play rook to c2 but again
that move Bishop to d1 is still in the
air so how do we get our Brooke active
in this position this is the oopsy-daisy
variation we're not happy about that
well I would say that well black would
probably let me just think give this a
thing for a second I mean wanted what's
my ideal setup my ideal setup would be
to involve this Knight get this Knight
on to the c5 square so I'm going to have
to kick this Knight out of the way so
after for example I move like a 5 Bishop
back I would be looking at this move
Knight c3 the idea behind the move
Knight c3 is to get my Knight to e4 so
I'm just going to put my right work okay
my name is Rex likes to say the
co-defendant Paretsky piece so even
though the [ __ ] 21 leaves a lot to be
desired
you don't mind training them and then
replacing that night right another
strong knight on e4 mm-hmm which also to
boot allows you that f6 Bush taking out
the ninety five exactly so I'm just
thinking that what Sam needs to do is
further activate its pieces the knight
on f6 gets into the game not a hundred
percent sure about this knight on c3 by
the way it might
end up being kind of finally placed on
the d1 right I wanted first of all to
get rid of whites to bishops right
because that's his one thing that he
does have going for him but I think that
you respect the two bishops even when
they're on you want a nephron but that's
the endgame so it's a lot different than
some of the positions where we're joking
about the Fisher Adam setup right and we
got something from Maurice Ashley um in
another game in quite a few games
there's some interesting things going on
Jen I wanted to point out this position
where a Cobian had gotten a very nice
advantage against Ramirez but he didn't
play quite accurately so he still has an
edge but what I want you to note is that
it's only moved 19 and Akopian has nine
minutes left on his clock of course
there's a 30-second increment every move
so for the he was gonna gain back at
least ten and a half minutes for the
rest of the game but he subbed nine
minutes right now and it's not like he
has some clear win in the position going
forward I mean he's just he's got a
normal position there's no mating attack
there's no squeeze play he's just played
the move a five chasing the Queen
backwards but he's gonna have to really
giddy up if he's going to make this
position happen for him because he's
definitely in some serious time pressure
right now
another position I wanted to look at
with the game between s Warren and zoton
ski this position as Warren is
definitely down upon but so Thompson's
gonna have some problems converting it
she's got the extra point on this side
she's gonna be trying to push this pawn
forward the youngster does have the move
Bishop to c4 right now trying to put
some pressure on this pawn they both are
at 18 minutes after 25 moves so some
time pressure there as well another game
I wanted to note something interesting
this game with 21 minutes on one side
that is for white and 13 minutes for
black between Frida and gray ev nothing
has been exchanged not one trade on the
board after 25 moves and they're going
to be closing in on time pressure really
soon so this one should be really fun to
watch as
time pressure starts to rear its ugly
head you just saw how gray of glancing
this clock that quick glance of
nervousness so it looks like and a lot
of these games it's gonna be about the
clock back to you guys
hmm that's a remarkable game fighting 25
moves no pawn captures no piece captures
I think the record is 44 moves I seem to
recall a game where 44 moves for those
of you following us you can correct me
if I'm wrong on that score but 25 is
quite a lot the hippopotamus very
flexible morphus type of defense and
josh hasn't been able to get on his
positional grippers yet but let's just
see how the maneuvering has gone from
the time we left it we were around these
parts where we had noted that Timur was
just castling by hand
spending several tempi to cover as h6
pawn bishop h2 Knight h7 very hard to
guess these moves this move I like
principally because it opens up the
possibility of c4 and it repositions the
knight to a better square 92 98 ok
similar idea black wants to bring his
knight to the c-4 square H 4 okay
finally somebody is throwing the paddies
here ideas of h5 perhaps in the position
94 Queen c1 boy a very big maneuvering
game and h5 by black c3 Queen d2 again
not too much is happening what's the
first pawn that will be traded or piece
oh boy yeah okay its total six is doing
a good job of stopping me from playing
any 4c for its total guesswork on my
part but I'm going to hazard that
somehow I don't know exactly how dark
square Bishop SAR going to be traded
first all right
I'll a interesting prediction and I'd
say I'm gonna go with Knights you think
a pair of nights will be traded okay
yeah okay I got your chances sushiro
okay we got a sushi roll on this one for
me I have two nights you only have one
though right you you said dark-squared
bishop I just said on ice okay so you
guys oh we didn't hit our bird have
drawn their game
all right guard its gate coming off his
first win of the tournament yesterday
now Mena drawly give the iron bird
alright let me just bring I saw it was a
car of time I didn't take anything
specific anything really
- earth-shattering happened in this game
essentially from the beginning the
players went down a very long main line
variation of the Carl Kahn one that I
played many times and went straight to a
well-known ending it goes to show you
how how advanced opening theory has
become all of these moves have been that
seen before
I dare say even by myself back in 1989 I
actually had a game in Canada where I
played this position is black I don't
think I play the move f7f five by the
way but all of the this whole end game
has been played before and nothing
special is going on still well we've got
a lot of action going on another game
so don't want to go on this one too much
it wasn't well right after 31 lose I do
have a great comment from one of our
friends over at chess comm who by the
way are sponsoring our best question of
the day a contest you get some premium
memberships over there for your
questions I'm in chess comm he says in
robot Williams the world junior
championships in Stockholm 1969 the
first capture was made on move 94 Oh be
serious deserves a membership come on
well oh no our friend
so yeah well take a look at that and of
course is Ken Rogoff who you might see
on CNN from time to time but I'm never
talking about us right Grand Master Ken
Rogoff IMF chief economist and now so
yeah we've got some interesting things
going on in attack them are bhajami on
crush that game did not go quite as we
expected and we've got more on that game
prime Maurice Ashley 90-plus moves
without a trade I don't think we could
put that game on television anytime soon
well this game though does belong on TV
why because these two fighters are now
in time pressure crush had a comfortable
leader the clock that's evaporated now
she's at 11 minutes to play the rest of
her moves
that's 18 moves that she's gonna have to
play with the 30 second ring increment
that's gonna give her back about nine
minutes but that's probably not going to
be enough in a position like this the
game proceeded after 95 Queen b6 9 to c6
the move King to h8 Bishop takes pawn
takes and now Queen to f2 and crush has
been sitting on this position with her
knight pinned to her Queen for quite
some time I think that she needs to find
something normal to do there lots of mo
she could make just for the rook on the
C file in fact there's no more fork on
the e7 square but she's taking her sweet
time here and getting into more and more
time pressure that could be dangerous
the leader in the tournament arena crush
on the women's side she had looked
totally dominant up to this moment never
in trouble but now definitely thinking
quite a bit it looks like she's finally
moved to see if we can get up to date on
this position she played the rook F to
e8 and now it's top tennis move but 13
minutes on top ten o'clock eleven
minutes on the arena's clock so the game
is definitely going to heat up in just a
few minutes so we'll keep our eye on it
here at the championships back to you
guys absolutely a critical game here for
the championship
Irina crush remember if she draws this
game in on wins they'll be fine at the
top and they'll also give top some
chances to get back into the tournament
with a lot of wins as well so it'll be
interesting to see how this game goes
but don't you see a lot of trades in the
air this last move by even that kind of
anticipating your potential Knight takes
d4 that her work will be activated right
as much as I'm excited for it to heat up
I'm wondering well there are too many
trades for it to heat up and off well it
was I was thinking that arena might have
wanted to play rook a four to be able to
double up on the a file one day put
pressure on the on the b-pawn but Tatia
had prepared a very nasty little trap
here that i wanted to share with our
viewers how about this one Knight takes
e5 you think that pawn on e5 is super
fortified really really well protected
and you were you were talking about
trades trading the Knights and stuff
like this this move Knight takes e5 can
be a really unpleasant surprise because
suddenly you can't take the knight
because of the pin and guess what I also
have a fork in the VIP in the position
and the knight on d4 has been under my
name and Maurice you've got some
thoughts on this one too I'm not looking
at that one I'm looking at something
else I just exploded on Robson vs.
molder I said molding with the white
pieces Robson we saw doubles his rooks
and Molenaar play this move b3 and
Robson went for it
rook takes on si - looks like the simple
trade of two rooks for a queen and pawn
in fact it's gonna be much worse
for white after this move Queen to c6
check the main problem is this diagonal
pressure here it's going to be big time
where to put the King where to hide it
if you try to tuck it in on this square
in fact it doesn't matter where you put
it
this monster move is gonna land on the
board Knight to c3 and that move attacks
this knight on a four and also pressures
this knight on f3
if white defends normally now black just
attacks like crazy with this move Knight
to c4 and now there's really no place to
put the King because it's gonna be about
this Knight this Queen this pawn and
this Bishop that's just going to swarm
into the position quite rapidly move
like this could just be met by 983
and a mate threat down here this this
pin is preventing this Knight from
moving to help no rook to see one
anywhere black is all over white it
should be a matter of minutes before we
see ray coming downstairs
to be interviewed because this is just a
wipe out on the chessboard guys last
hour the Queen only attack we're gonna
take a quick break but we'll be back for
more from the US Championships and u.s.
women's you don't want to miss a minute
because we are gonna have some exciting
time pressure especially in that crucial
game in the Women's Championship crush
abuhami on while you're waiting for us
to come back we as usual have a Bobby
Fischer gem for you
yes and we are back at the 2014 US Chess
Championship and u.s. women's chess
championship and we have a grandmaster
Maurice Ashley with our latest Bobby
Fischer puzzle yes Jen normally when a
piece is pinned is not supposed to be
able to move but strong players know
that they can always break the rules
because it's not really a rule it's just
simply a principle and so in this
situation it's one thing to try to move
a night like a bishop it's another thing
to just simply ignore a pin because
you've got something else juicy going on
and Fisher found that with the move
Knight to f5 threatening a very nice
Knight to e7 check and mate black
however has this move rook takes g2 with
check might have thought why you can't
move your knight I have a check but
after King to f1 suddenly the mate is
still on tap and the rook cannot go back
to g7 to guard that square what can you
do about it
Sherwin play the move b6 and Fischer
continued with the check and after King
to b7 Fischer got rid of this piece on
the square the rook is hanging it was
being defended by that bishop and no
longer is Sherwin made one more move
rook back but then he realized that
there were a couple of wins here the
simplest ones was being Knight to d8
check saving the night so that he can
then save the bishop and Black Stars
gonna simply be down a piece so he
decided I'm not playing the great Bobby
Fischer down a piece makes no sense so
he resigned so that is the solution of
our puzzle for the day well it looks
like we're throwing out a lot of puzzles
today so you're getting your money's
worth out there are watching us back to
you guys and we have a result Jenn
that's right ray Robson has defeated
Mackenzie boner and I I saw that Mac was
really down on the clock but he was
under trouble ever ever since that rooks
sacrifice maybe I would win a toss it
back to Maurice to take us through those
final moves
that I gave ray the victory here from
Ray Robson soon so you got any questions
for him you know tweet at us at us chest
champs hashtag us Jeff Jeff that is
chance yes guys exactly what we thought
would happen pretty much did happen the
move rook takes on c2 and the double
capture on this Square and then Ray did
find Queen c6 and now the king decided
to go to D 2 instead of B 2 or anywhere
else it didn't matter because this
monster move was dropping on the board
Knight to c3 that move attacking this
Knight through to the rook
this Knight cannot move obviously rook
to d3 was played and now the move Knight
takes a 4 just ripping apart the
structure on this side B takes a 4 was
played and then Knight to c4 check and
this is just horrible right now all
sorts of problems for the white pieces
he didn't play King eetu in the position
but that could have been met by the move
Knight to b2 and what to do here hole
position is is creaking I move like rook
b3 Queen to c2 and it's just horrible
this Knight ready to go to another
monster square maybe after this a square
like this
he's just being squeezed here black this
a white decided he had seen enough also
maybe his time was just so bad it looks
like he had only two minutes on his
clock and he said that's all she wrote
giving his opponent due respect you know
gen we would have liked to see him play
a little bit more just so we could see
the finish I know you have proposed this
idea that grandmasters should not resign
I don't think they're gonna take a back
that cause anytime soon when they're
being humiliated so Mulder decided he
had seen enough back to you just kind of
change the way you look at it but let's
go on quickly take a look at it talk to
have our bhajami and Irina crushed cuz
things have changed and I gave it seems
to me that taka is going for it but I
don't know if there's enough to justify
the rover that she's performed in this
position we got a question about that
earlier in the broadcast actually while
you pull up the game rover rook up and
over right
rook lifts that a nice way a nice term I
think did you coin that because I hadn't
heard it before test kids I went to in
the child will be talking about the
rover and of course that's not something
you forget
no absolutely we had left it we had left
it more or less about these parts I am
arena had just played the move rook on
f8 to e8 solid move avoiding that trap
this is the rover that we've been
discussing rook came to c3 and rook over
to h3 menacing the various sacrifices
here on the h6 square and then after
rook h3 it's kind of one of those if it
works you're a genius
if it doesn't you work it's just kind of
what's it doing over there so queen b7
so now was cream b7 she gets out of the
pan and now knight c6 is back to menu
exactly sorry for my terrible arrow
drawing and there was a trade and I tray
exactly trades trades and now Queen
takes d4 I believe has been executed on
both players they've got about 13 moves
to make toast I'm controlling both well
under 10 minutes I'm reading was about 7
and a half and talked up with about 5
and after Queen takes d4 rook takes a 2
on the board
okay so now luckily protective I mean
even though that working-age 3 doesn't
seem to be doing much it can't get right
back into the game with a single move so
what do you think yeah who's got the
edge here well the first point is
obviously we were very happy to have our
past pawn the problem is we can't
advance it because that would expose our
G to pawn to Queen takes G - checkmate
doc - I've actually dealt with that
problem immediately by playing work -
you three exactly now she's guarding the
board on g2 and now she's bringing back
some hints of rook takes f6 into the
position but it's not gonna work quite
yet because the King on 8 1 7 it's it's
close but it's not quite working because
there's a back rank mate for white -
zakharik mate for us and even if we
dealt with that it seems that black is
defending
well still I I think that the big thing
here is that I actually prefer white now
before I liked arenas position but in
this exact position of four major an
endgame with the only major pieces it's
about who has the better past but who
has the more potent pawn and in this
case it's clear that white pawn on d5 is
gold golden and she's looking like you
said that that sacrifices like rook f6
as well as simply pushing the pawn d6
and I think arena defending champion
arena crash has seen the game turn
against her and this is it we're gonna
come right back to this game after our
interview with Grandmaster Rey Robson
who just won a very exciting game
against McKenzie Molinari he's with
Maurice Ashley indeed Grandmaster Robson
played a thrilling game one you gotta be
happy to be a part of ray welcome to the
show we don't have a lot of time but
this moment here you play this monster
move rook to c4 did you feel that you
were completely winning at this point
yeah I originally I wanted to play b3
which is probably just much better but
then I saw the idea of Roxy for Group D
for rock FC 8 and basically there I'm
gonna play b3 or take on c2 and either
way look like it was hopeless for him
yeah the computer agrees with you where
did he go wrong in this game I think
perhaps one of maybe his first mistake
was taking on f6 and move 11 after that
I already had a very comfortable
position and I think maybe black is
already slightly better even and my
veins just kept growing you got to be
feeling good with a win who do you play
tomorrow and what are you thinking about
going into that game I believe I'm white
against Akopian
and it's a pretty big game for me
because I guess we're both in contention
for Olympiad spot so potentially if I
win maybe I would be tied with him in
the tournament so hopefully I can try to
press him with white indeed a big game
before I let you go one last question
what's your opinion of this game with
our tournament leader against I'm sure
well Sam is very close to to winning I
think the a for pawn is weak and no
blacks obviously up upon so yeah maybe
Alex was gonna get his first loss big
words good luck in the rest of the
tournament thanks for joining us thank
you so Alexander monument in trouble for
sure ray Robson with a big game tomorrow
for a spot on the Olympic team
potentially back to you guys
hasn't ray been one of our most decisive
players in the tournament boy he's been
he's been throwing out patties but
receiving a couple as well what
what's his overall record in the event
bring some to three points three out of
six so that's right he's had four for
decisive games yes it's a more of an
emotional roller coaster than say
another player who took the one who took
the most Rawls right mm-hmm and that
really shakes up the standing so if
Lenderman is gonna lose right yeah that
blasts the field wide open
by the way arena did play the move that
you mentioned counter play with the move
rook army let me just go back she has
just played the long move rook e8 to e2
doubling on the second rank and also
preventing white from playing d6 83
exactly making look for King setting up
for those rook sacrifices that you've
mentioned Jen rook takes f6 I'm assuming
six nails in the air because also with
that rook leading eighth ranked rook
takes f6 pawn takes f6 Queen i6 King
h-having we've got Queen g6 and made on
G a piece I say so a terrible move I
just but a terrible move to show at the
variation that white is dreaming about
sacrificing a rook
and making a checkmate pattern in that
way but I'm looking at a different move
for black I'm thinking that arena could
play a move like pardon me maybe not
rook on a to d2 because in this case I
do have rope to d2 but perhaps the other
the other rook rook on e to the d2
trying to get rid of this very important
pawn on the F on the D Phi square let's
just continue the the variation for a
move or two rook down check I'm still
dreaming about checkmate rook takes
check this out this is going to be wild
at least this variation so I want to
give a checkmate over here but I think
white Allen's first with rook takes h6
how's this for a nice checkmate Wow with
King takes you've got Queen 18 and
you've got that same create me precisely
so this game really heating up and what
at the time taking down she's still
thinking she's got less than three
minutes I think what's going on is that
she's looking at some of these
variations exactly as Irina generally
they used up big time pressure problems
but lately she's mostly solved them so
that means if she's thinking mm-hmm it's
because there's tactics that are about
me right and it's not easy to control
them and again there's it yes so she has
played the move I anticipated she did
play this move rook on e to to d2 and
again the variation we just looked at
very briefly was the Queen coming to c5
eyeballing the f8 square and I just
thought that this continuation may be
very favorable for white because of that
huge threat rook takes h6 landing with a
checkmate some very exciting variations
now we'll talk to a play we need to see
if I were there any other moves in the
position it seems that that's definitely
the most logical we'll keep our eye on
that meanwhile we've got Maurice
another key battle in women's
championship a swan pursuit on ski last
time we checked it husky was very much
on top what's going on our well she has
extended her advantage in this game look
at the white king it looks terrible
this happened in time pressure after
this move King to g7 it's Warren decided
instead of staying solid and just
sitting there she played the move before
a bit unusual to make a pawn move like
this around your king and zoton ski it
was like waving a red flag in front of a
bull because she played them over a 5 in
response looking to rip apart the king
side after Bishop to b5 rook back to d8
+ s Warren couldn't figure out anything
else but to take on a5 b takes 85 and it
looks like she might be in serious
trouble here this queen is thinking
about coming down to d1 with some back
ranked issues afoot this rook has to
watch out because of the pin on the b
file both sides with of under six
minutes actually the tomski has six
minutes and six seconds and it's Warren
has only 455 and Counting with six moves
to make even with her increment her
position is so bad it looks like she
will lose this game another game to take
a look at where there was a blunder
actually in this position Akopian
ramirez just going back a few moves
there was a very deep idea in this
position after actually to this point
here this moment black played Knight f8
and both of them are in time pressure
cobia now down to 231 and Counting after
Knight to f8
white missed a very sweet move a window
a pawn Bishop takes it looked like this
was a mistake because of Bishop to b3 no
down he saw that but check this out
after rook to e1 rook takes e5 white
could have played Queen to be to forking
the two pieces and winning upon a time
pressure mistake and oversight by a
Cobian it doesn't matter if you're
winning if you don't have time on the
clock you're not gonna find good moves
and it seems like this is an opportunity
that I Kobe and missed and now he's in
some severe time pressure now as 223 you
saw I just got that extra 30 seconds
having to try to keep up and on the
women's side another
that's interesting is the game between
bargain SkyTeam alakina although this
position looks like bag and sky teh had
a big edge and now has fretted it away
in time pressure again if she plays the
move King to g2 here after this check
then rook to f8 causes severe problems
for her she's gonna have to drop back
with her rook and then the Queen will
drop back and she's studying this she
has such a great position but she's
given Melek inna counter play so time
pressure is making fools of everyone it
looks like in the championships they're
up against it now trying to figure out
exactly what to do so that they don't
actually lose the game on time or make a
horrible blunder back to you guys and
speaking of time pressure we've got our
defending champion grandmaster irina
crush was less than a minute left on her
clock after touch of did play the move
that you suggested this Queen history to
Queen to c5
now I'm sure she's starting to see these
variations with Queen f8 and work AGA
look h6 nice and that's why probably in
this position what are our other options
can't you just defend the back rank
let's say she plays rook to AE not a
pretty move yes to make it look like
that Rob it looks like she's done
something similar instead of guarding
her back rank with a piece she's played
King 287 with only 5 seconds left when
she played that mom no way she was down
to 5 seconds so she seconds so she got
the 35 seconds Wow
you're right she could have dropped back
with her rook
there are so many tactics here that you
suddenly have to be aware of I'm just
looking at a silly line of sacrificing a
rook but in this case unfortunately
there is a check that mm allows you to
hang in there but that was not the move
that arena played you say gee King h7
allows so I can still play f8 here but
in that case she's not committed she has
not in that case committed herself to
capturing the pawn on d5 so right so
work they defy work takes f6
would still be possible but but what
what can black do because I'm seeing
that if Queen Network a a we have rook
takes G oh we don't we don't have well
you if he went Queen FA with the idea
that after rook a8 you wanted to meet
this move with rook takes g7 it's a
wonderful tactic you're trading yeah
you're trading rooks bit but guess what
there's a small problem the pawn on d5
is in the way and there's no protection
for the fawn on g2 instead type of um
thinking in herself low on time she's
got less than three minutes Wow almost
down to two minutes Wow I didn't figure
out how to continue here and there's
maybe this move King h7 was a good move
what I'm sure it is about this move
well a simple and dangerous looking
continuation here is just a move rook to
e1 with the threat of putting a rook on
the e7 square that move would amp up the
pressure in the position she would have
to play arena something like rook 2d
work to e2 she'd have to think about
whether or not she should take this pawn
which could still lead to the move rook
down to e 7 and we'll take a look at
that if she takes here instead on d5
there's still this move rook to e7 and
this position to see whether or not this
is something she wants to play this this
line is quite interesting they'd have to
evaluate this with a time ticking down
I'm not sure what's actually going on
here it looks according to the computer
that this position is fine for black and
moved like route to g5 would keep her in
the game but she has to calculate all of
it because she's going a pawn down in
this line after rook takes this pawn
will hang so much to think about in a
tense moment in the game guys
it did happen rook to e1 was played on
the board and again arena with just
about 8 seconds left in the class when
she played it so 38 seconds under clock
now worked you want work takes d5 and
we're anticipating a rookie 7 oh my gosh
Tatia is he
like reach at hand and everybody live
you're gonna see and she's played it and
arena in trouble even though I hear what
Marissa said that the computer thinks
that in a position like this black can
play but they trust me when I say having
those double rooks on the seventh is
enough to scare anybody
I mean after King g8 I'm thinking you're
just gonna move the rook and you're
setting up for all kinds of mates black
is gonna have to step back with a rook
and of course the computer may defend it
you know perfectly well but Totti EV
could be an upset Irina's a happiness at
least here you know the next three moves
are captured that's two she'll get the
increment that's right five seconds
absolutely yeah Irene I used her time
well and not to fall into those twenty
five queen of eight things right but I'm
sure arenas gonna be disappointed that
she that she gave these marvellous
options to Tati F which she did find you
know applause kudos to Katya for her
fine play but boy arena is gonna be
upset with herself because she's she's
the difficult side yes that's that's
right so you think it's clear that
keeping the works on the board rather
than you think hot tub is gonna consider
taking on a g5 and take you Anna b5 oh
I'm sorry
Utah TF can't get into an ending where
she could be just a pawn to the good in
this case exactly just a second so we're
back here so we we know the move rook g5
was forced I just thought like is on the
board
okay rich is thinking about her
right because you're right she could
simply go into this ending one pond
ahead I suspect that's closer to a draw
than anything yeah so I would probably I
would want to keep I think so and just
to force my opponent into some kind of
passive play because again these rooks
on the seventh it's it's easy enough for
the computer to say yeah blacks got
great defense and everything else but
playing against the rooks on the seventh
is very very frightening for a human
player and it's very easy to see ghost
threats and to Aaron one thing for sure
the absurdity of the time pressure is
calming down so Maurice you got
something for us in another hand indeed
it looks as though while arena is in
trouble her main rival anna sitarski is
about to win the game by force you take
a look at this position she actually
played it not the most accurate move but
it's not going to matter here we saw
this position after B takes a five on
the board white played the ball of h4
and it looks like they're moving ahead
of us let me just take this off so that
I can show you what happened in the game
in this position after B takes a 5h4 in
pressure by the youngster the 13-year
old Queen to d1 posting deep into the
white position Bishop to c4 was played
and then the move a for Bishop c4 was a
serious error
she should have played a for herself but
she allowed a4 and the board Bishop b5
and that was a blunder of her piece
although the move a3 was even stronger
than that one after King takes this rook
could have flushed into the game and
after the King moves the King is just
under terrific attack another rook check
is going to happen here and the King
this piece will be won by force but with
the King all the way down the board that
can't be good
but instead of that the simple move
after Bishop b5 was just to play Queen
to be one check and after King to a3
Queen takes on b5 upper piece no reason
to make any moves here for a soir on so
it looks like the youngster is going to
go down in this game and
torski is gonna rise and at least be
tied with arena
if arena does not lose her game which
actually could flip flop them in the
championships back to you guys that's
right Maurice and we do have an official
result sham clan has drawn first blood
of wonder man right anyone's game
absolutely incredible anyone can win
dramatic events here in round six I was
going to say that it looked to me that
Sam was cruising to victory the a for
pawn was falling he had won he had been
upon up for some time ever since
Letterman got into trouble let's just
face it out of the opening Sam had a
very easy opening put pressure one upon
and now in the final position too
connected passed pawns for black Sam
just about to play the move rook d7
keeping his King nice and solid
even this knight on e7 makes a bad
impression and then the next thing you
know these pawns are rolling
so Lenderman gave it up first loss well
he started the tournament I started the
round with a powerful point ahead Sam
Shanklin like Ray Robson he was making
an even score after this victory right
so we have to see whether garea will win
his gamer of coping rinse his game but
otherwise Lenderman could still be in
the clear lead after this loss so plenty
of excitement right gotcha and we do
have Sam Shang Lin and he's getting set
up with his interview with Grandmaster
Maurice Ashley here they are yes with
Grandmaster Sam Shanklin after a victory
against what looked like the runaway
tournament leader Alex Lindemann first
of all congratulations on your win thank
you
how did you feel i what point did you
feel like this game is mine like you
could just see that the win was coming
last night when it started raining I
realized that would knock the pollen out
of the air and I wouldn't have allergies
so I thought I would be on much better
form than I played previous rounds no
but in all seriousness CB in the opening
he played I think it's been played
before and I don't think Black has put
the best
think the theory regards it is slightly
better for what and I think that's
completely wrong and so very quickly I
think he just got an unpleasant position
and I think he just didn't react very
well it's this Queens gambit declined
which must be a huge surprise for him
but I've seen the kind of surprises he's
been pulling on other people and the
quality of his target specific
preparation it's been extremely
impressive so I just I wanted to dodge
any of that and play something solid so
you just got out of his his theory
because you played something different
yourself yeah I dodged any surprise he
could possibly throw I wasn't
anticipating him to be worse by move ten
but uh you know I just thought I should
put salt and play a long game and okay I
think when he played rukka t1 I every
single game has gone Bishop she threw in
another computer says if what doesn't
play it he's worse but I didn't actually
underlies any other move so I had to
find it over the board but knowing I was
better and having some time advantage
and historically I've done well against
London and I was pretty confident you
have a good record against and I believe
it's two wins and two draws at out of
four games or my thing about somebody
else I must have been in lunderman six
times final
oh no he's it's funny one campus key or
Sarah when Nakamura and Caruana declined
their invitations and the next spots
went to Ramirez in London I'm like yep
there's one win one loss for me was
based on history but uh no I mean Alex
was playing amazing chess this
tournament but he had a bad day today
but I'm sure he'll be back with bigger
tomorrow he's got a tough road to go
with with Kamsky and owners Chuck with
the black black yeah
back-to-back who do you blame ro neski
and what's your record against him oh we
actually been put in a very long time I
used to demolish him like ten zero when
we were kids but he actually won the
most recent game which is probably the
most relevant so I don't know I don't
think past history will really have an
effect on I think we're two completely
new players now so so it's a new
tournament for you a great video feeling
pretty good the first half was really
tough for me I felt like I was both
playing poorly and catching bad breaks
and yet today everything just turned
around and all of a sudden I'm back to
an even score I've played all the top
guys I saw off the lowest three rated
players left to play and I have three
whites in the last five games so I think
thanks for turning around well that
about sums it up congratulations and
good luck in the rest of your games
Busch Grand Master Sam Franklin shaking
up the leaderboard by defeating
Grandmaster
Lindemann it's anybody's tournament now
shake up indeed that is boiling very
very dramatic well Sam's looking for
more than just being a spoiler he wants
to he wants to get on that podium in the
last five around having played those
four being four out of six right and
heavier men having a lot of top thanks I
mean we might not see a very big score
win this championship but that means
anyone's in it and that's perfect by the
way for Alex ownership because we know
he's such a difficult player to beat
Alex only shook is looking at a plus two
plus three result if he think of a get
two plus three I'm sure at this moment
in time
he's favored to be a playoff if he can
get two plus three but a big big big
victory today for Sam Shanklin anyone
catch up to women despite the fact that
he lost the only two players who could
do it would be a Kobe intergraph
so Colby and play Ramirez in this
position where he has two bishops I'm
guessing you like VARs game but is it
enough is it enough this is a very nice
squeeze by the way the position I have
on the board White's King nicely
centralized but it's really about these
two bishops raking the set across the
center and over to the Kings side as
well Wow just great pieces by white in
general yes so definitely some chances
for version of Kofi and to catch the
leaders and such a such a great
personality a bar has but yesterday when
we joked that he might draw all his
games wait a second he might win two in
a row right right you didn't like your
comments he's punishing you for first
such as exactly and we have another
another guest so uh Alexander Letterman
is getting set up for an interview
gracefully coming down after a difficult
loss and we thank him and appreciate his
sportsmanship in doing that because it's
always tough especially in a tournament
that he's been playing so well
and looking forward to a good result in
this round before he plays the two
beasts with the black pieces Maurice
thanks guys with Grandmaster Alex
Linderman after losing to Sam Franklin
Alice when did you realize that there
were difficulties in this game oh I'm
sure I remember I think after he played
Bishop a4 and then the ideas was to take
on d5 and I couldn't really defend the
c3 and very conveniently that just
caught me by surprise I thought I'm fine
relatively equal maybe chances to press
in the end game with two bishops if I
get a chance
but in those dynamic chances I knew
there might be some but I didn't see
them but it turned out that they were
there and he played a fantastic game I
thought indeed he did he said he thought
he caught you by surprise in the inning
did he absolutely the I expected the
groom filled maybe the Slav but this
particular order d4 d5 c-46 that's
something I was actually trying to avoid
against Ray Robson that's why I played
c4 and Sam never played exactly like
that and so I was not sure really what
to plan with 3 and then the classical I
and I played what I was gonna play
against curry if against that but it
turned out I know deeply enough and the
position had some some dangerous to say
the least and it looks like he navigated
through them very well I don't know what
the computer says but I did the best I
could I battled but I guess sometimes
it's not enough sometimes you just have
to accept losing and move on for the
next one the road gets tougher now you
get black against both chomsky and
owners chuckle Sarah Lee because today's
game was very tough and I had a couple
of very tough games early on I mean
every game was tough so I wouldn't
necessarily say just because of the
names that the games would necessarily
definitely get tougher because I'll tell
you what today was very tough so I don't
know if we can get tougher than this
worried
we appreciate your graciousness coming
down to join us good luck in the rest of
your games thank you grandmaster alex
Lindemann seems like he still might be
in the lead at least tied for the lead
guys going forward in the championships
back to you guys just the guy to
not allowed to get to him that that
leave is kind of achieved in a strange
way right with a lot of decisive results
not a couple wins in a few draws so you
were assessing the size of clothings
advantage here definitely has an edge
big enough for a winner do you predict
at all big enough for a win
all right so for when you think that
Akopian is that it is an odds-on
favorite of tying for first after the
end of this round I think that what he's
going to do is going to play a move like
f4 f5 it might seem a little bit anti
positional but what he's really doing is
keeping this night on f8 squeezed after
f4 f5 the idea would be to play King III
f4 followed by E Phi E 4 E 5 just
opening up the position for the two
bishops if you can if white is able to
target that g7 pawn that's gonna be all
she wrote that's right beautiful bishops
now wonderful coordination yeah our game
Josh Ford algorithm whatever that was
the famous hippopotamus and we had a
little bet going and I had to tell you
Yaser you owe me a couple of sushi rolls
Oh No the Ducks we're bishops are still
on the board exactly the dark services
are on the board and well it was a night
for a bishop I feel like that's a win
now you get the whole thing but we'll
share well sure because we're buddies
so anyway eventually we got this
position so blacks got the two bishops
but White has a better blonde structure
do you think it's balanced do you think
we're gonna see a drop well I bet I bet
upon trade and that's what happened that
wasn't but I want what was the bet what
do I get
man you get the check Maurice obviously
you're welcome to you just gotta bring
the wallet bring the credit bring the
plastic I'm always the last against uh
nobody thinks about me but you know
at least I got the point rate I'm
feeling good about this okay well let's
see really what did happen because who
got what trade when and where Maurice is
running a tournament in Vegas you know
what they say always bet on pawn that
right always bet on pawns actually
manner that chess wheel and there are a
lot more pawns than there are any other
piece so it's basically the same fact we
played you beat me yes at the Hall of
Fame there was an exhibition right
that's right we were playing the role
with the rule that chess wheel which is
a combination of chest and chance
because even if you had this nice little
positional and you can smiie you might
you might just I attack your queen and
you don't you don't spin a queen I take
your queen there you go there you go and
we got like something might have
happened in our big matchup in the
Women's Championship I'm predicting a
draw it looks like hey does look like
these guys are in the middle of the
board so it does like look like arena
did save what was an awkward position
Rachel I think what happened there was a
touch of instead of going for your line
went for the pawn up line and Irina very
well prepared and both the opening in
the endgame and probably just knew the
theory of how to draw and I see so
wasn't able to well we'll come back to
that in a second we just take a quick
meander at the game between Joshua Dell
and Timur acharya because that of course
is a key game yes right you were just
talking about that yes and again these
split pawns on the c7 and a six squares
are a hindrance and blacks position but
he does have the two V's I would expect
him to play a move like oops I'm sorry
what could white might play move like
Bishop f2 well f6 hold on no maybe just
a second maybe I'm evaluating this wrong
altogether
oops when I was pretty equal ie7 I'm
beginning to think maybe just maybe
- bishop f - josh is very very fast and
it's not easy at all
and maybe he stand
a little bit better did you just think
about this occupation of c-5 exactly we
should be fine right if Bishop b5 I was
just trying to assess this bishops of
opposite color ending that is a kind of
funny one you don't see a pond like this
every single day on h6 but it is past
probably a draw okay but it's just a
funny bishops of opposite color ending
that I'm looking at for the first time I
don't I don't see gari of winning this
position shall we see how Irina held the
draw
yeah I'm assuming that we're gonna hear
from one or both of the players so we'll
also be able to talk to them about this
kind of time pressure wow that was so so
close
wow that was something special well go
back a few moves because I was saying
that I thought Zen yoke should keep the
rooks and after the move rook g5 she saw
a pawn
why not she captured and said I'm a pawn
up I can't lose maybe I can win but
Irina did the normal routine Brookes
belong behind pass pawns and furthermore
she got a very active King I like this
active King for the defense
the king is walking in and I don't see
any winning chances here mb7 a draw was
offered I assumed the draw was offered
because after move like f5 white is
going to be unable to make progress
white should be careful not to step back
and allow King g3 with serious threats
of checkmate can't escape the black pawn
on f5 is doing a good job of locking
became an f4 from sac side yeah I would
say it's just gonna get to King and to
vs. King into in a very short order but
I look forward to the ladies abroad
Abraham here and crash sharing their
thoughts because it was drama right and
we've got a actually with some thoughts
on the dramatic game a Kobe and Ramirez
which were you think that a Kobe is
gonna steamroll down yes well I just saw
a move that you know makes me feel warm
inside its kind of thing you have good
memories about and that is in the game
between a cobia and Ramirez you see this
position he's got these two pawns
it looks like sooner or later is gonna
be able to push the pawn to e5 create a
passed pawn in the position but he
played a different move that what I
first saw this kind of move I was like
what and then it's like wow the move
f5 now he has a backward pawn on the
e-file so you think this has had to be a
bad move in fact it's the best move in
the position this move controls the
knight it's not able to go to g6 it's
not able to go to East six it's not able
to go to d7 already and once that Knight
is shut out the game now it's what can
whites other pieces do he has the two
bishops this reminds me of a game that
last kirby kappa blanka back in the
early 1900s Benaroya Lopes imagined an
idea in the reuleaux past crossing over
into this which was a Slav opening so
you get this position where the pawns
sitting on f5 Ramirez played the move
rook to e7 but the computers are saying
this is dominant we're up a piece let's
start trading pieces off rook to d8 is
the toughest move to deal with in this
position this Bishop is just floating
the black pieces have no connectivity
that's the main problem in the position
while this King will be able to move the
pawn can push later this bishop can post
on this Square on c5 total command of
the position does white have here and it
looks as if a Cobian is going to
continue to surge in this game if he
wins he'll tie with linderman for the
lead after being just after just drawing
four games in a row he can win this one
if he can pull it off he'll be tied for
first this looks like it will happen but
still a long way to go in this position
guys
nice I am and I am in fact expecting f5
in King F 4 and E 5 as well and it just
looks roses as you say for white let's
see what he has won that game mm-hmm
as expected she was winning a bishop so
now she's joining I read a crush in the
leaderboard right and I'm just looking
at the game between Camilla and my
alakina and I'm wondering in this
position between Camilla if if white
doesn't have it has Mel Akina missed a
shot here her last move was d4 d3 looks
like a wonderful cementing move you
protect the rook but I'm just wondering
is the move Knight e5 available for
white because there's no attacking
attacking blacks Queen I'm anticipating
Queenie for right do you see a better
move than Queen e4 and then I wanted to
take the pawn and I'm sure rook d2 was
the intended move but attacking the
Queen attacking the knight and maybe her
analysis stopped here without her
considering the move Queen a 1 check
bishop attacks Queen Knight captures c5
grabbing another pawn and I think
Camilla can confidently keep capturing
blacks pawns because if we attack the
knight like with Queen c6 or something
like that then I simply move my queen to
the the defense of the night and I'm one
two three pawns to the end all right
well looks like there could be some
potential trouble here for Mela Hina
but meanwhile we've got Tommy in from
the US Women's Chess Championship who
just drew against Irene across in a game
that looked like it was getting pretty
heated in high pressure and both players
are finding a lot of good moves with
very little time in their class they did
indeed she's with Murray's a sight
indeed Jen with Tata have Abraham er and
after a terrific fight with the
tournament leader
welcome to the show first of all okay
what what was it like I mean you guys
were in time pressure for it seemed like
14 moves or so did you were you ever
worried that you were gonna lose because
of the clock or that you might be able
to push her to make a mistake well I
mean she was getting really long time so
I thought maybe she couldn't make a
mistake somewhere but thank goodness she
had like four seconds maybe at the clock
at one at one point when she moved and
got the increment yeah I think when she
went rogue d5 at some point she had
really a long time and I think the final
move to maybe show spent a long time all
the time in that game did you feel like
you had an advantage at any point during
the game um I'm in the position was
really tactical but I think just
structural in my position maybe the
words because of my a tune before pawns
but there are so many tactics and my
knight on c6 I thought maybe I have
something I think it's just fun all the
good ones so this struggle you you have
played there before the the score is
sort of lopsided but you've defeated her
before did you feel that you had to go
for this game like no matter what the
tournament is not its midpoint to try to
beat her no I just kind of wanted to
play solid and take my chances as they
come so what's the situation now I mean
a draw keeps you is it a point behind
her in the tournament thanks I think
point behind the Heron Donna maybe and
you have played on already so the rest
of the field sort of the the lower end
of the field for you what do you think
about your chances moving forward I mean
it's just one game one time I think this
tournament is more level than it used to
be it's not just Anand Irena just
winning all their games against everyone
so they've drawn couple of games so I
think it's just gonna be for every game
it's gonna be fight for all three of us
yeah well thanks
so much for joining us and good luck in
the rest of your games thank you doctor
Abraha me on after nicking the
tournament leader a little bit slowing
her down we wish her the best in the
rest of the games back to you guys
if I can't just get in one quick
question about when the forward position
and the rook g5 whether there was
consideration for keeping the the rooks
on the seventh but my two points hanging
like roll cages on the rocks you seven
yes well I thought the rook goes on the
eight and yeah I guess that's better
oh yeah I thought about this you might
try to excuse a little here you the the
two rooks on the seventh are always very
frightening for for everybody
this wasn't a moment move 36 as well I
mean you did grab the pawn when you when
you had a chance so that has to be a
consideration the clock yeah I mean III
thought I would have more chances with
the three again I didn't realize her
king is gonna get to acting I thought
maybe I'll have some chances because I
know yeah here I mean I don't see how to
continue here though maybe looks Derek's
a fine
well the computer is not that impressed
by Rho C Drive so doesn't look like much
and you certainly had a pawn in hand so
we'll see I should know him the rest of
our games you got a chance to look at
that later of course and we'll look to
the rest of the rounds back to you guys
Thank You Maurice all right what what
games are remaining I think they're
dropping like flies here are a lot of
results what happens with these these
games that it seems like none of them
were done and then all of the Redang
right exactly but we do have a couple of
critical games still going home we
talked about a Kobe and in his advantage
against Ramirez right which seems so
picturesque and then for del gray of
most likely a draw but you like for
those chances a little bit more
one her game yes we've got a few games
left in the Women's Championship
subpoena for sure and Irina Zen you me
and them Koba and behind said he may
lukina they're all still fighting I see
very good and I just I think you just
took a look at buying sky key in alakina
and you were pointing out to move Knight
to e5 and indeed that move was played
right so Camilla has played 95 well I'm
an old pawn grubber you know give me a
chance to grab a pawn and I'm a happy
camper and I just I'm very sensitive to
the little darlings and I saw that there
was a fork in the position thanks to the
pin against the rook and the Queen and
quite a pond to win and she only have
half a point so this would mean a lot to
her to get into the scoreboard strong
player and certainly doesn't want to be
a great veteran of the women's
tournaments I've watched Camilla gosh
it's really been terribly long I think
close to 20 years that she's competed
and competed very well terrible start in
this event the lots of things went wrong
losing to our 13-year old didn't help
that that that games won on a single
move and remember the four Queen's
position who will forget that but we
have our defending champion in studio
that's right I read a crash and worried
fastly with grandmaster arena crush
first of all welcome to the show
Thank You Maurice terrific draw huge
fight in this game not exciting enough
for you that was pretty exciting we were
we definitely enjoyed the struggle and
the time pressure at one point you had
something like four seconds left on your
clock you had to make a move to get the
increment to move forward I mean you
must have your heart beating fast you're
making a joke of course since I hate
increments yeah but tell us about the
game did you think you were fine coming
out the opening yeah I thought I had a
very comfortable position coming out of
the opening I couldn't really have hoped
for anything better
solid positional game I thought black
has
you know obviously some some ways to get
a strategic advantage there are things
that white wants to avoid like getting
stuck without bad LightSquared Bishop um
so it was pretty happy but I cannot say
played that great I mean well I never
really managed to become actually better
I thought white was always you know
doing fine I didn't feel like I was
under some pressure around you know like
this points right here a little bit yeah
computer degrees not much nothing
um nothing too specialized it was always
sort of petering out into a draw but I
would have hoped to get a position where
I'm the one trying to win yes and this
was a really a critical moment right
here at Queen c5 well actually I kind of
thought that maybe Tess have had
blundered this move rook to d2 and that
d5 pawn I guess probably not maybe she
saw that she has some resources here and
after Queen c5 it was just so sharp and
like for example we can show a couple of
lions there is the move like it's a
Queen d5 here Queen D 5 and this Queen
f8 Czech Queen g8 and rook takes f6 good
that it spins everywhere oh that's been
scary to see the board oh yeah now I see
rook aged 6 is actually a threat to even
win the game and if I trade Queens my g7
pawn is just going to be defenseless so
it's kind of funny both of us have an
attack on the G pawns but her attack is
good as mine is not because so I mean
there was a lot of a lot of unpleasant
lines here another one is I could
capture the pawn with the rook and now
queen of fates there's actually a nice
line here King h7 and rook f6 yeah this
looks just awful for black because then
I noticed this rook h6 is a main threat
right so I mean I don't even have time
to get my rooks to the first rank to
threaten her King okay yeah the computer
says there's one move exactly I need to
defend the h6 pawn but obviously this is
a hard move to sort of senior
calculations and this doesn't look
appealing at all for black very in fact
actually that's funny position just
just pointed out because it looks like
rook f7 if you if you don't notice it is
crazy but certainly you have rook takes
h3 and and the rook can't leave because
you're the one who's mating so that
would just be too wild to be looking at
all those crazy ideas in a position yeah
so did you feel like fortunate to get
out of it alive at the end absolutely